Clark County School District has tried
to keep up since 1998 it's built dozens
of new campuses as our Valley grows but
one town has felt neglected by CCSD for
years John lagler looks at how their
requests are finally being heard
they put a clip on this side he's worked
here longer than anyone else Laughlin
athletic director Tony petrick and he's
all about routines the routine of
working out the routine of working here
I have been here for a while 34 years
the routine of wishing something would
get done about where he started all
those years ago Bennett Elementary I
love that campus it's a great little
campus but it's old Bennett was built in
1986 it's basically Portables covered in
Stucco they feel like the ugly stepchild
for nearly 10 years 8 news now has
profiled Laughlin's efforts to get a new
Elementary School the county has given
us not one nickel little happened
outdated and dangerous Don Estes is
Laughlin's principle I would say since
1986 there has been conversations of
when is Bennett going to get a new
school facility the new building itself
now after years of asking Clark County
School District has decided to do
something it's putting all of Laughlin's
students here at the Junior and high
school campus yeah I don't think I've
stopped smile filing but it's not just
moving the children CCSD is building a
new Wing modernizing what's already here
and bringing Laughlin's schools up to
date total cost 32 and a half million
dollars our students need to realize
that regardless of their backgrounds
regardless of where they come from our
goals as schools is to build that hope
and maintain that belief that we can be
successful it's welcome news for a rural
community that often feels ignored I'm
not surprised that it's finally
happening but I'm surprised like I said
that it's taken this long now Laughlin's
weight can be lifted about time this is
going to be fun this will be cool in
Laughlin John langler 8 News Now